i'm going back to the very beginning of
the mcu we have a keystone event and
that event is tony stark becoming iron
man
he's forced to build these weapons for
an organization and that organization
was the ten rings
welcome back everyone this is my full
shanxi movie review finally releasing it
around the world hopefully you've had a
chance to see it if not i recommend you
go check it out i will also be doing
full easter egg breakdowns post credit
scene videos the next couple of days too
so if you're new to my channel be sure
to subscribe to get all those for those
of you that are huge martial arts movie
fans and you're really really bummed out
by what they did with iron fist the
shanxi movie is a giant step in the
correct direction and it basically the
beginning of this giant new franchise in
a direction that marvel has never gone
before i've made the black panther movie
comparison before whereas that movie
sort of set up this whole new area
inside the mcu this whole new mythology
that wasn't anything like any of the
other marvel movies that had come before
so even though he's going to eventually
cross over with the avengers as they
sort of tease through the course of the
film i'll explain that in a second too
they actually do a really good job of
asking a bunch of questions during the
film that you are excited to watch them
answer in future sequels they answer
most of the big questions that they
raised during the film like the biggest
things about his character where does he
come from how do his powers work what's
going on with the mandarin how do these
characters connect with the rest of the
marvel films but also at the same time
raised a couple other big questions that
they won't answer until they get to the
second film kevin feige has already said
that they have a lot of ideas where
that's going to pick up but they haven't
given any kind of release date to that
yet and where is the black widow movie
dealt with a little bit of marvel phase
4 stuff like the black widow post
credits scene was a marvel phase 4 scene
because there's a huge time jump at the
end of the movie till after avengers end
game and even though spider-man far from
home actually takes place after shangxi
in the timeline of marvel movies so it
should be a marvel phase 4 film that was
really more of an epilogue the way they
build it for avengers end game in all
the marvel phase three stuff so shanxi
takes place before the events of
spider-man far from home but it actually
feels like a genuine marvel phase 4
movie where everything is new and it's
pushing the plot forward in marvel phase
4 the way you would expect a marvel
movie to do and if there was confusion
about when this does take place in the
timeline it does take place after the
events of avengers end game like a good
while after end game after things have
chilled out life has gotten back to
normal around the time i would say
falcon and winter soldiers happening but
before the events of spider-man far from
home is spider-man no way home because
you do see the sanctum during the movie
and it's not covered in snow and wong
isn't talking about it or addressing any
kind of issues that are happening at the
sanctum so clearly whatever's happening
at the sanctum during the spider-man no
way home trailer is happening after the
events of the shangshi movie kevin feige
a lot of the other producers were also
talking about a lot of the cameos and
the crossovers like you have abomination
and wong showing up during the movie
very clearly during the trailers they
said they also considered having the
ant-man characters show up during the
film i feel like it's not a huge spoiler
to say that there are no big ant-man
characters that show up during the film
even though a good chunk of the film at
the beginning takes place in san
francisco there were a lot of questions
about that early on like we saw the bus
chase happening through san francisco so
people wondered wait a minute this is
the exact same area where ant-man and
the wasp took place but the way they
said it they wanted to keep the movie
relatively self-contained which gets
back to the whole black panther of it
all black panther did cross over with
other marvel movies there was some
continuity tying it to captain america
civil war in avengers infinity war
because that was the next movie
happening right after so you have that
white wolf post credit scene where shuri
shows up but they didn't mention
avengers infinity war during that so
it's very self-contained the shangshi
movie felt like they built it to be that
way too like you could watch this movie
without having seen some of the other
marvel movies but there are a lot of
easter eggs in background details tying
it to other previous marvel movies they
even used some footage from other marvel
movies inside this movie most of that
was in service of paying off the iron
man easter eggs and the iron man films
the way they talked about the mandarin
during those if you have been following
the marvel movies since early 2006 when
they announced the iron man film they
were going to make one and they were
building up to the avengers kevin feige
was teasing the avengers even back in
2006 long before they did the first iron
man film with the new studio set up the
way things work now is they're more of
an opportunity for a crossover here and
there with marvel characters in a movie
so say
somebody might show up in a hulk movie
down the road i think if you you
listen to the characters i name that we
that we work are working on currently
and you put them all together there's no
coincidence that that may someday equal
the avengers
i think uh
you may remember at that 2006 comic con
he said that they were going to use the
mandarin as the villain of the film but
then when they got into production
famously pivoted and changed it to
obadiah stain since then they've already
kind of answered a lot of those
questions but this film actually does
fill in a lot of the gaps some really
important parts of the shangshi movie
are dedicated to filling in those gaps
and fixing some of those past mistakes
that they made so i was happy to see
that they're trying to explain no no it
was wen wu tony leyoung's version of the
mandarin this whole time influencing
things he was behind the events of iron
man 1 it's just you didn't see him till
now simuli was great as the shangshi
character he's one of those actors who
can do a lot of the action stuff himself
because he's actually really good at
martial arts just on his own but he can
also do all the comedic beats and the
really heavy drama stuff as well marvel
really likes their main protagonist to
be relatable characters so they kind of
have to be able to wisecrack but also do
the heavy stuff as well and sort of
getting to the iron fist of it all
because marvel did attempt a martial
arts project before but just wound up
being a total disaster no matter how
badass the shanxi sequels wind up being
some of you might still have iron fist
ptsd but the movie does go a long way to
washing that bad taste out of your mouth
kevin feige kind of saying to the fans
no no don't worry we can actually pull
this off we can do a really really
awesome martial arts movie i feel like
it's not a spoiler to say there is no
iron fist stuff going on during the
shangshi movie but i feel like in the
future a lot of people have speculated
that that would be the place to
reintroduce that mythology or that
character if they want to do a new
version of him please recast i'll say
right now just please recast a brand new
actor like i said the shengshi movie
gets into a whole new mythology so it
doesn't have anything to do with khan
lun or the capital cities of heaven
anything from the iron fist comics i
will do my full post credit scenes video
on friday and i'll talk a little bit
more about what they set up in that one
of the post-credits scenes does tease
something larger going on with the 10
rings of power so in the comics the 10
rings of power are made by the mcluhan's
they're kind of like space dragons in
the marvel universe they don't really do
any of the mcluhan's during the movie
and they never fully explain all the
details about the ten rings themselves
you learn that the mandarin found them
thousands of years ago and started using
them they gave him immortality but they
only teased where they come from this
other realm that this group of people
comes from it seems like it might wind
up being their version of the mcluhan's
inside the mcu but that is one of the
big questions that they do not answer
that they're just leaving for the
sequels so i will talk more about what
that means when i do my post credit
scene video tomorrow but when they do
get to doing the sequel i am excited to
see how that influences and changes the
mcu but it broadens things in a cosmic
way that i was not expecting when you
think of kung-fu action movies in the
mcu you tend to think more of ground
level action just because it's a lot of
hand-to-hand combat but the movie does
get much bigger much more cosmic than
you're expecting and speaking of the
fight scenes the action i've already
done a couple videos talking about some
of their big fight scenes and obviously
we have that mortal kombat style
tournament happening with wong the
abomination in shangxi later in the
trailer the fight choreographer they had
in the film was from the matrix movies
he was also one of jackie chan's top men
he wound up passing away after the movie
was finished so it was very unfortunate
but he was a badass fight choreographer
so all the traditional types of fights
like hand-to-hand combat martial arts
fights are badass early on one of the
few minor complaints though is that when
they get to the third act and things
sort of escalate to the more cosmic
realm they start using more of their
superpowers to fight the choreography
gets a little bit messier and it's just
not quite as exciting as some of the
traditional hand-to-hand fights most of
you on all my trailer videos seem like
you're already big fans of tony liang
from his martial arts movies or other
movies that he's done with one car y
most of the movies he's made have been
pretty fantastic he actually said that
this movie is the first time that he
actually worked with an american crew on
a film so if you haven't seen any of his
films before this i'd recommend you
check them out he's done both badass
martial arts films but also a lot of
really awesome drama films as well
anything of his from wong kar wai is
fantastic so be sure to watch some of
those the interesting thing about their
dynamic shanxi in the mandarin during
the film is it is way more of a family
vibe that they've got into in previous
villain relationships in marvel movies
like before the shangshi movie i feel
like the biggest relationship you see
between a villain and their relative
family members was during avengers
infinity war and avengers end game with
thanos and gamora like him throwing her
off the cliff that was actually a really
powerful moment but at the time that was
a brand new thing for marvel like oh
this giant cosmic villain actually has a
family that he cares about in a
relatable kind of way usually that's one
of people's biggest complaints against
marvel movies is that the movies are
only as strong as the villains and some
of the movies have pretty terribly
written villains the difference with
tony lang's mandarin character is that
he actually has a genuine arc during the
film start to finish like you learn how
he became the mandarin in ancient china
thousands of years ago how the legends
about him were spun how he became this
great warlord using the ten rings of
power then how he fell in love started
the family had shangshi his sister how
he stopped being the mandarin for a
while and then why he became the
mandarin again one of the other
post-credits scene teasers gives you an
idea for what's going to happen with the
future of the 10 rings organization in
the future of the mcu like i said i will
talk about that tomorrow when i do my
full post credit scene video all the
supporting casts do a really solid job
too michelle yo is amazing in pretty
much everything that she does so no big
surprise there the team they put around
simulu was great although there's not a
whole lot of his sister in the movie
they kind of hype her up in the trailer
is a pretty big character and she is a
pretty big character they sort of tease
that at the end of the film but a lot of
what you see from her in the trailer is
about what you get from her in the film
she doesn't have a lot of speaking lines
she just kind of shows up is really
badass for a little while has some good
scenes with him and then is important
for the end of the film and then you
just kind of tease a larger role for her
during one of the post-credits scenes so
i'm assuming that when they get to the
sequel she'll be a much bigger character
even though it seems like aquafina is
mostly in the film just for comedic
relief they're pairing together her and
shangshi together as a comedic peer
actually works pretty well during the
film they actually work as a couple even
though they themselves are not a couple
although they kind of tease that there
might be some kind of romantic
relationship with them in the future
they play it a little bit like the iron
man pepper potts relationship only she
isn't pining over him the way that
pepper potts was clearly in love with
tony for a long time before he ever
noticed her like imagine a funnier
version of pepper potts who isn't
totally in love with iron man at the
beginning it is a much more important
part of the plot throughout the film
than pepper potts was in the first iron
man film i was also very happy that they
finally explained what happened to
trevor after that one shot all hail the
king the iron man 3 one shot during that
they teased that the real mandarin is
after him for revenge using his name
creating all this negative attention
around the 10 rings so is that getting
into huge spoilers yes they do answer
what happened to trevor in a satisfying
way overall i do feel like it's gonna go
down as one of the better marvel movies
like the good half of marvel movies
because there are so many of them now
maybe enough to break into my top 10 not
quite top five like it's not captain
america winter soldier good but it's
still a pretty solid movie my top five
in my top 10 marvel movies tend to
shuffle after every new marvel film a
little bit but i do give it a lot of
extra points for pushing into this fresh
new territory the same way that the
black panther movie did like here's
something brand new that you've never
seen before but that feels like a marvel
movie so if you have seen the movie or
once you do have a chance to see it do
write your reactions in the comments
below like i said my shanxi post credit
scene videos will post tomorrow i'll do
full easter egg breakdowns this weekend
there is a lot of really exciting stuff
that they do set up for the future of
the mcu in avengers 5 during the movie
speaking of people ignoring wong's
advice you can click here for my full
spider-man no way home trailer video in
doctor strange going off the rails in my
full what if episode 4 dark doctor
strange episode video thank you so much
for watching everyone stay safe and i'll
see you in the next video
[Music]
[Applause]
you